ZDF heute live herzlich willkommen der
Angriffskrieg Russlands gegen die
Ukraine könnte Monate oder Jahre dauern
davor warnt Nato-Generalsekretär
Stoltenberg heute am Kriegsziel Putins
die ganze Ukraine zu kontrollieren und
die internationale Ordnung neu schreiben
zu wollen habe sich nichts geändert nur
die Taktik ändert sich offenbar die
russische Armee will sich jetzt auf die
Ostukraine und den Süden des Landes
konzentrieren
die Bilder die wir sehen diese Bilder
verheißen nichts Gutes sie zeigen
offenbar russische Panzer Nachschub für
die Front in der Ukraine in den letzten
Tagen wurden sie von Russland aus in
Richtung der ukrainischen Grenze verlegt
tja was plant Putin darüber sprechen wir
heute in der Sendung wir freuen uns über
Ihre und eure Kommentare wie immer in
die Kommentare oder wenn ihr oder Sie
die App nutzt an die Mailadresse auch
eingeblendet ZDF heute-live@zdf.de
zunächst hören wir rein in das Statement
des Sprechers des Generalstabs der
Streitkräfte der Ukraine heute zum Stand
dessen wovon die Ukraine ausgeht was
Russland als nächstes plante
der Feind konzentriert sich darauf eine
offensive vorzubereiten mit dem Ziel die
volle Kontrolle über die Gebete Donezk
und Johanns zu bekommen
die Bedrohung durch See Luft und
landgestützte Raketen bleibt bestehen
die Besatzer fügen den
Verteidigungsanlagen der Infrastruktur
und den Wohngebieten der Städte
Brandschäden zu
tja um das zu vertiefen begrüße ich die
militärexpertin DR Claudia Major von der
Stiftung Wissenschaft und Politik
schönen guten Abend nach Berlin Frau
Mallorca sie haben den
generalstabsprecher gerade gehört bevor
wir über die Ziele Putins sprechen über
die wir sicher im Laufe der Sendung noch
ausführlich reden werden lassen Sie uns
über seine mutmaßliche Taktik sprechen
Kiew ruft die Ukrainer jetzt dazu auf
den don-bust zu verlassen was ist zu
erwarten
was wir jetzt gesehen haben ist eine
regruppierung der russischen Truppen das
heißt sie ziehen sich aus dem nämlich
aus dem Norden zurückgezogen von Kiew
und verlegen nach dem Süden in die
Region Don Bass das heißt was vermutet
wird ist ein ein Angriff im Don Bass
möglicherweise die landgruppe
herzustellen bis zur Krim möglicherweise
darüber hinaus bis Moldau und
transnistrieren das heißt wir haben eine
Konzentration auf den Osten und Südosten
in der Region Donbass
von welchem Zeithorizont sprechen wir da
es ist davon die Rede dass die Truppen
sich zurückziehen dass sie sich neu
aufstellen ist damit zu rechnen dass
dieser neue Angriff in den nächsten
Tagen erfolgt oder erst in den nächsten
Wochen es ist relativ schwer da die Zeit
festzulegen weil einerseits die Truppen
aus dem Norden runter verlegt werden
müssen Richtung don-bas weil sie
umgruppiert werden möglicherweise auch
mal ausgerüstet werden müssen das heißt
wenn es jetzt eine gewisse Pause gibt
heißt es nicht dass Russland von seinen
Zielen abgerückt ist sondern dass das
wirklich eine Frage der neue Aufstellung
und Greg Gruppierung ist und dass man
sich darauf einstellen muss dass es in
absehbarer Zeit diese Offensive im Don
Bass und darüber hinaus geben wird dann
schauen wir uns diese Gebiete mal
genauer an wir haben eine Karte
vorbereitet wo man noch mal genau sieht
wie die Gebiete dort sind das ist nicht
die Karte sondern das ist schweres
Kriegsgerät was wir sehen auf dem Weg in
die Ukraine und hier ist die Karte wir
sehen die Gebiete im Osten und Süd
Kosten wir sehen Mario Paul eine Stadt
die immer noch schwer umkämpft ist wir
sehen haarkiv auch von dort werden
Kämpfe gemeldet und wir sehen die
besetzten Gebiete eben im Süden und
Osten was können sie uns nicht dass wir
das nicht schon oft gehört und gelesen
hätten auch seitdem dieser Konflikt in
der Ostukraine schwählt und das tut er
ja schon lange was können Sie uns über
die Gebiete dann jetzt luhansk über den
Don Bass sagen warum ist das ein
taktisches Ziel jetzt für Putin also die
Gebiete dann jetzt und Johannes sind
seit 2014 unter russischer Kontrolle
kurz vor dem Ausbruch des Krieges hat
Russland diese
Gebiete als unabhängige Volksrepubliken
erklärt das heißt aber die Faktor sie
sind unter russischer unterrussischer
Herrschaft und die Idee die jetzt auf
russischer Seite zu existieren scheint
ist dass man von dass man nicht nur
diese Teilgebiete dann jetzt und
Johannes sondern den gesamten Don Bass
eins nehmen möchte und dann diese
Landverbindung rüber das kann man auf
der Karte sehr schön sehen bis zu Krim
zu ziehen und damit der Ukraine auch den
Zugang zum Asowschen Meer zu verwehren
und möglicherweise dann das kann man
auch sehen dann weiter noch rüber die
den landkorridor rüber bis zur Moldau
und transnistian was auch von Russland
besetzt ist zu ziehen und ich kann
Entschuldigung ganz kurz genau auch dazu
haben wir eine Karte wo man die von
Ihnen angesprochenen Gebiete auch noch
mal sehen kann noch einmal hier im Osten
sehen wir aber wir haben auch eine Karte
wo man Transnistrien und die Republik
Moldau sieht da haben wir es und da
erkennt man auch sehr gut was was das
bedeuten würde was sie gerade
beschrieben haben genau man kann das auf
der Karte sehr gut sehen man sieht die
Republik Moldau und dann die Region
transzenistrieren wo russische Truppen
stehen das würde aber auch heißen wenn
man das auf dieser Karte sieht dass der
landkorridor von dem Don Bass bis zur
Krim und dann weiter bis franziskien de
facto heißen würde dass die Ukraine kein
Zugang mehr zum malsoffen und auch kein
Zugang mehr zum Schwarzen Meer hätte und
dann der Faktor der Osten und Südosten
russisch
selbst wäre und das scheint das Ziel der
momentan Umgruppierung zu sein wir haben
gerade über den zeitlichen Horizont
gesprochen hier kommt eine Frage von
einem User namens rex91 über Youtube wie
wahrscheinlich ist es dass Russland den
Krieg am russischen Feiertag am 9 mai
der quasi Tag des Sieges ist
beenden möchte so müsste das eigentlich
weitergehen hier auf Dauer tut der Krieg
ja Russland auch nicht gut was bedeutet
dieser 9 mai möglicherweise für die für
die russische Taktik
Sachen hier unterscheiden das eine ist
wenn wir uns die momentanen
Entwicklungen ansehen einerseits dass
die Ukraine deutlich stärkeren
Widerstand leistet und auch in der Lage
ist Gebiete zurückzuerobern und
andererseits Russland an seinen
Kriegszielen trotzdem noch festhält
müssen wir uns darauf einstellen dass
dieser Konflikt sehr lange dauern kann
dass dieser militärische Konflikt noch
sehr lange dauern kann weit über den 9
mai hinaus der 9 mai ist ein sehr
wichtiges Datum weil dort Russland
traditionell Sieges Paraden abhält und
an den Sieg über den Faschismus im
Zweiten Weltkrieg erinnert und wenn wir
uns die Rhetorik ansehen die Russland in
diesem Krieg benutzt spielt es sehr
häufig auf Faschismus Nazis
denazifizierung an um auch die
Öffentlichkeit auf diesen Krieg
einzuschwören und auch damit Gräueltaten
wie beispielsweise in Butcher zu
rechtfertigen denn ein Krieg gegen den
Faschismus rechtfertigt auch sehr harte
Maßnahmen das heißt dieser 9 mai ist
wichtig weil das einmal noch mal ein
Punkt ist um wo Russland versuchen wird
auch die Bevölkerung seine Unterstützung
zu sammeln wo es aber wahrscheinlich
auch gewisse Erfolge wird vorweisen
wollen oder müssen
ein User namens Anonymous fragt über
Youtube Frau major glauben Sie das Putin
Kiew abgeschrieben hat das glaube ich
nicht man kann die momentane russische
Umgruppierung in zwei kann man zweifach
interpretieren man kann einmal sagen
russland hat tatsächlich seine Ziele re
interpretiert und hat sie nach unten
korrigiert und sagt nicht mehr wir
wollen die gesamte Ukraine kontrollieren
sondern wir konzentrieren uns auf den
Donbass die andere Interpretationsweise
ist zu sagen es ist ein rein taktische
Maßnahme das heißt russland hat gemerkt
sie kommen momentan Kiew nicht weiter
ziehen sich vorübergehend zurück
verhandeln ein bisschen konzentrieren
sich ein bisschen mehr auf den Südosten
aber sobald sich die Möglichkeit ergibt
werden sie zu den ursprünglichen Zielen
Kontrolle über die Ukraine
Regierungswechsel Systemwechsel
zurückkehren wenn man sich die anderen
Verlautbarungen von offiziellen
russischen Stellen anguckt zum Beispiel
Sprecher vom Außenministerium da kann
man die alten Ziele immer noch hören
also dieses Ziel der Demilitarisierung
was der Faktor heißt die Infrastruktur
zu zerstören und auch das Ziel der
denazifizierung
ganz schrecklicher Euphemismus heißt das
heißt eigentlich ein elitenaustausch in
der Ukraine das heißt wenn man diese
verschiedenen Punkte zusammenzieht
scheint Russland sich gerade taktisch
zurückzuziehen aber von dem
übergeordneten strategischen Ziel die
Ukraine zu kontrollieren nicht
abzurücken und das heißt auch sobald es
wieder geht ist sehr gut vorstellbar
dass auch die Angriffe auf Kiew oder auf
andere Teile der Ukraine wieder losgehen
dann lassen Sie uns noch mal auf das
militärische zu sprechen kommen und auf
den Zustand auch der russischen Armee
wenn man sich anschaut die Bilder aus
budja dann haben wir natürlich in den
letzten Tagen gesehen dort wurden ganz
offensichtlich Kriegsverbrechen verübt
von russischer Seite und wir sehen aber
auch wenn wir die Bilder aus Butcher uns
anschauen wir sehen aber auch Chaos
Zerstörung ukrainische Einsatzkräfte
sind mittlerweile gekommen um die viele
Munition von der Straße zu räumen das
können wir hier gut sehen Butter und
viele andere Orte nahe Kiew sind völlig
verwüstet verschlammte Straßen
ausgebrannte Fahrzeuge kaputte Panzer
fast Menschen wieder zu den Bildern Frau
major dieser zerstörten Panzer kommen
natürlich auch Zahlen heute sagt ein
ukrainischer Gouverneur des 18.600
russische Soldaten gefallen sein das ist
eine Zahl die man nicht verifizieren
kann und die weit entfernt ist von der
Zahl die die Russen kommunizieren das
sind 1.351 die Wahrheit liegt irgendwo
dazwischen aber zu sehen ist dass die
russische Armee ja offensichtlich weder
das erreicht was sie erreichen wollte
dass sie nicht gut vorankommt und dass
sie hohe Verluste erleidet hat erlitten
hat was bedeutet das für das weitere
Vorgehen
wir haben von Anfang an das Krieges
gesehen dass oder wir haben am Anfang
gesehen dass Russland das ursprüngliche
Kriegsziel nämlich schnell auf Kia
vorzustoßen und einen schnellen Sieg zu
ringen das ist dieses Kriegsziel nicht
erreicht hat aber von dem übergeordneten
politischen Zielen nämlich die Ukraine
zu kontrollieren ist es nicht abgewichen
es hat er versucht der ist Vorgehen
anzupassen und was wir im Laufe dieses
Krieges gesehen haben ist dass das
russische Vorgehen immer brutaler und
immer rücksichtsloser geworden ist auch
ein Krieg hat regeln wir haben das über
Tiere Völkerrecht das festlegt was
erlaubt ist und was nicht erlaubt ist
und da steht zum Beispiel auch drinne
dass das keine Angriffe auf
Zivilpersonen geben soll oder dass sie
Angriffe sich auf militärische Ziele
konzentrieren sollten und was wir
gesehen haben im Verlauf dieses Krieges
ist dass es Angriffe auf zivile
Infrastruktur gibt auf Zivilpersonen
zivile Infrastruktur ist alles was die
Zivilbevölkerung zu überleben braucht
vom Wasserwerk energiewerk
Lebensmittel und alles und wir haben in
diesem Krieg gesehen dass diese dass das
immer weiter missachtet wurde also
Backup Angriffe gesagt auf
Zivilbevölkerung zivile Infrastruktur es
gibt Berichte über Plünderungen über
Tötungen es gibt Berichte über den
Einsatz von verbotener Munitionen wie
thermovarische Waffen oder Streubomben
das heißt was wir beobachtet haben ist
nicht das Russland seine Ziele verändert
hätte es hält daran fest sondern dass
das Vorgehen immer rücksichtsloser wird
auch trotz der eigenen hohen Verluste
aber dass sie daran festhalten
Frau major danke bis hierhin wir
sprechen gleich miteinander weiter ich
möchte aber die Runde erweitern und
einen Kollegen tatsächlich mit ins Boot
holen in der Ukraine selbst zugeschaltet
ist uns jetzt der Journalist Max
Grabowski er arbeitet für telekanal Don
Bass ist jetzt in nipro also
nordwestlich von mariopol ich weiß nicht
ob wir die Karte uns gerade noch mal
angucken können damit wir auch alle
lokalisieren können wo sie sind Max ich
sehe das können wir gerade nicht ah doch
das können wir genau da sehen wir es
noch mal die Ukraine
wir sehen unten Mario Paul wo sie bis
vor zwei Wochen waren und jetzt sehen
wir eben der nipro wo sie sich jetzt
aufhalten können Sie uns können Sie uns
schildern was sie in Mario Paul gesehen
haben
guten Abend
die Situation in Mario paul ist
tatsächlich extrem schwierig und es wird
immer schlimmer immer schlimmer seit
einem Monat
haben die Einwohner der Stadt nicht nur
normale
Lebensumstände sondern sie haben nichts
was man im 21 Jahrhundert überhaupt zum
Leben braucht wie Wasser Trinkwasser wir
Heizung wie Gas zum Kochen und die
Temperaturen sind ja in Mario Pall zu
dieser Jahreszeit bis -10 Grad
und Menschen sind des öfteren die
Menschen sind einfach des öfteren
einfach erfroren sogar in der eigenen
Wohnung und das wurde bewusst alles so
zerstört durch die russischen Besatzer
um das zu vernichten um das zu zerstören
und es hört keine Minute auf die
Angriffe kommen einer nach dem anderen
und es wird aus Kanonen geschossen das
sind auch Streu Munitionen Bomben
Streubomben das wird von der Luft
angegriffen mit Raketen mit
Mörsern
angeblich soll das Ziel militärobjekte
sein aber die ganze Stadt komplett
durchgehend wird er Quadrat für Quadrat
fällt für Feld einfach vernichtet mit
Kanonen aus der Luft mit Luftangriffen
und anderen Mitteln und dann kommt die
russischen Armeeangehöriger die
russische Armee und versucht das zu
besetzen und es ist ja humanitäre
Katastrophe ist zu wenig gesagt das ist
tatsächlich eine
Katastrophe für die ganze Bevölkerung
und es ist einfach
und unmenschlich einfach die Menschen in
der Schlange nach dem Brot zu erschießen
nach Lebensmitteln es ist einfach
unmenschlich die Luftschutzkeller zu
zerbomben und die Gebäude anzugreifen in
denen sich Menschen verstecken es ist
tatsächlich Terror
das
internationale das Internationale Rote
Kreuz meldet heute dass es gelungen ist
500 Leute aus der Stadt rauszuholen das
sind natürlich sehr wenige und wir sehen
es gab immer wieder Versuche Menschen
aus der Stadt zu holen die gescheitert
sind was wissen sie darüber
das Rote Kreuz hat gar keine
Möglichkeiten ich habe selbst bekannt
die beim Internationalen Roten Kreuz
arbeiten und sie haben versucht selbst
ja sich zu bewegen also sogar mit den
Abzeichen ja das Internationalen Roten
Kreuzes sie wurden beschossen sie wurden
nicht durchgelassen ich glaube er ist es
absolut egal wer sich dort einsetzt
es die russische Seite gibt zuerst
Garantien und beschießt dann alle
konvoice alle Fahrzeuge und die Menschen
werden ständig umgebracht dabei es gab
keine einzige Möglichkeiten von den
zugesagten Korridoren
die genutzt werden konnte
haben diese Korridore funktioniert aber
man muss zuerst nach Bergans kommen und
das ist ja sehr risikovoll obwohl
die weiteren Korridore ebenfalls
mehrmals beschossen wurden und es gibt
kommen durchkommen die russischen
Truppen erscheinen vor dich zurück
sie arbeiten für telekanal Don Bass wie
kann man sich ihre Arbeit jetzt
vorstellen ganz praktisch wie berichten
sie worüber berichten sie mit welchen
Mitteln in welche Gebiete können Sie
derzeit
es ist ja nicht ganz zu treffen
wir hatten ein Studio im mariopol und
das war mein Arbeitsplatz und dieses
Studio ist zerstört es bereits
vernichtet ich habe in den ersten Tagen
des Krieges versucht weiter zu Arbeiten
von dort aus unserer Sendungen zur
auszustrahlen
das war unsere
journalistische Arbeit wir haben ja
versucht maximal die Menschen auf dem
Laufenden zu halten und zwar
tagtäglich stündlich wir haben auch die
Einheimischen die ihr Einwohner der
Stadt versucht auf dem Laufenden zu
halten wo man sich verstecken kann wo
die Luftschutzräume sich befinden aber
es gab ja vom ersten Tag an Probleme mit
Strom mit
Internetverbindungen und wir haben
insgesamt ja nur wenige Tage überhaupt
Aussendung bleiben können und dann sind
wir ins Internet gegangen
um Kontakte zu halten mit allen Menschen
die wir noch in unserem Gebiet in
unserer Region erreichen konnten ab dem
4 März war alles vorbei war nichts mehr
möglich deswegen ist das ja ehemaliger
Sender er existiert nicht mehr und ich
habe ja mit freiwilligen nur Flugblätter
verfasst um mit diesem Flugblättern
zumindest die einheimische Bevölkerung
der Stadt auf dem Laufenden zu halten in
dieser Form
und User namens Anonymous schreibt
gerade über Youtube Herr Grabowski ist
ein mutiger Mann Hochachtung das möchte
ich Ihnen an dieser Stelle gerne
weitergeben
danke schön das ist angekommen das sehe
ich Herr Grabowski nun heißt es die
russische armee-verlagere ihre Einsätze
jetzt eher in den Südosten des Landes
was erwarten Sie für die kommenden
Wochen
ich kann nur
die Verschlimmerung der Situation
erwarten man der rechnet und mit dem
Schlimmsten
unser Chef der nicht
Militäradministration in Donezk in
Lohans es ist ja gamelitai und sie rufen
die Bevölkerung auf diese Gebiete zu
verlassen
diese Wiederbevölkerung soll raus hier
sollen als Freiwilliger in anderen
Regionen aushelfen es ist nicht nur
lebensgefährlich das würde sogar unseren
verteidigen schaden
der Angreifer eben die zivile
Bevölkerung
am meisten im Visier hat
und das würde auch die Armee daran
hindern frei zu handeln und ihrer
Verteidigung zu gestalten die ganze
zivile Bevölkerung sollte tatsächlich
einfach diese Gebiete verlassen und wenn
die Armeen aufeinanderprallen dann habe
ich glaube ich einer der reale Chance
für einen Sieg und die zweite Seite der
Medaille besteht darin das Putin zur
Zeit wütend ist er hat es für dich nicht
erwartet dass er auf dermaßen starken
Widerstand stößt jetzt ist ihm klar
geworden er kann schakov nicht annehmen
die er kann Kiew nicht einnehmen und nun
fällt natürlich alles auf Donbass der
Russland endet die Taktik
sagen viele sagen Experten aber ich bin
der Meinung es gibt nur eine Taktik sie
bleibt unverändert seit dem Ersten
Weltkrieg seit dem Zweiten Weltkrieg
ganzen schicken so viel
Menschen so viel Soldaten in den Krieg
wie es nur geht und es wird mit der
Masse versucht ja ein sink zur Sieg zu
erringen wir verteidigen uns heldenhaft
aber letztendlich alle Kräfte sind
endlich wir können nur tatsächlich
versuchen diese Masse abzuwehren genau
vor diesem Hintergrund was erwarten sie
von Europa vom Westen von Deutschland
sie und die Menschen mit denen sie vor
Ort sprechen
erwarten natürlich ihre Unterstützung
und zwar zweierlei in zweierlei Hinsicht
selbstverständlich in Richtung
Sanktionen
Sanktionen verstärken persönlich gegen
den russischen Präsidenten
gegen
reiche Russen gegen anderer Russen die
in den Ländern der Europäischen Union
wohnhaft sind die ausgereist sind sie
sollen endlich mal kapieren was hier
abläuft und wenn die Menschen klarer
denken können wenn sie tatsächlich das
begreifen was dort abläuft dann kann es
vielleicht die Politik kann es helfen
die Politik Russland zu verändern und
ich sehe nach wie vor dass viele das
überhaupt nicht verstehen sie sind durch
die Propaganda geblendet
und zum zweiten muss man den Menschen
zeigen dass es überhaupt nicht stimmt
was vor der russischen Seite behauptet
wird
die neuen Nazis sind ja die Russen
selbst das sind ja nationalistische
Ideen die dort propagiert werden die
dort aufgestellt werden und die haben
Schuld an allen den Opfern in der
Ukraine und die zweite Ausrichtung des
weiterspielen Schwerpunkt Essen
natürlich sind natürlich hier
Lieferungen von schweren Militärgerät
wir brauchen sie wie nie zuvor ich habe
heute und die Nachrichten verfolgt
Deutschland hat heute auch den
Waffenlieferungen neuen
Waffenlieferungen zugestimmt wir danken
Ihnen dafür und ich hoffe dass wir in
der Zukunft noch enger
zusammenarbeiten der Feind der zurzeit
uns bedroht bedroht auch die ganze Welt
Herr Grabowski eine letzte Frage noch
von Matu auch über Youtube ein nur
schwer zu ertragender Zustand selbst aus
der Ferne was gibt ihnen Hoffnung Herr
Grabowski
mir gibt in erster Linie einfach der
Hälfte heldenhafter Kampf unserer
Menschen Hoffnung es sind Frauen es sind
Männer und zwar überall Mario paul ist
komplett umzingelt komplett
eingeschlossen
die russischen Besatzer geben den
Menschen als sogenannter humanitärer
Hilfe die zuvor unseren
Transportfahrzeugen abgenommen wurde an
der ziviler Bevölkerung weiter aber ein
Teil der Stadt ist wird trotzdem noch
verteidigt ohne
nachschubmöglichkeit ohne Pausen
zwischen diesen Attacken es gibt auch
keine Möglichkeit zu schlafen ein paar
Stunden zu schlafen das weiß ich von
unseren
verteidigen von dem
Regiment und seinen Mitgliedern und es
gibt dort auch unsere unsere Mariens die
dort alles verteidigen und sie sind
tatsächlich echter Helden und das kann
man nicht mit Worten wiedergeben und es
ist etwas Unbegreifliches was sie dort
zustande bringen und wir verstehen und
wir sehen
tagtäglich dass unsere Soldaten
tatsächlich einfach fest entschlossen
sind unser ganzes Land wieder zu
befreien und
ich jeden Fleck dieses Landes bis
zuletzt zu verteidigen heute ist ja der
41.42 Tag
seit einem Monat mehr als einem Monat
ist die Stadt bereits belagert und wir
stehen trotzdem nach wie vor wir halten
diesen Angriffen stand und wir sehen
manchmal sogar ukrainische Fahnen an den
auf den Gebäuden das sind die Ukraine
ihr Land verteidigen und das gibt mir
Hoffnung
sagt der Journalist Max Grabowski vielen
Dank in die Ukraine vielen Dank dass Sie
mit uns gesprochen haben alles Gute
und damit schließen wir
und
damit schließen wir damit schließen wir
den Dank aus der Ukraine haben wir noch
gehört damit schließen wir wieder an an
das Gespräch mit der militärexpertin DR
Claudia Major von der Stiftung
Wissenschaft und Politik Frau Dr major
sie haben es gehört was die Ukraine auch
brauchen sind mehr Unterstützung sind
mehr Waffen auch wir sehen gerade
aktuell in den Agenturen das
US-Außenminister blinken zum Auftakt der
nato-beratungen die ab heute zwei Tage
lang in Brüssel stattfinden auch noch
mal sich dafür ausgesprochen hat den
Druck auf Russland weiter zu erhöhen und
die eigene Verteidigungsfähigkeit der
Ukraine zu verstärken und auch die
eigene Verteidigungsfähigkeit der NATO
wenn man davon ausgeht dass Russland
diesen Krieg nicht gewinnen kann weil
man damit auch ein Zeichen setzt dass
man keinen Angriffskrieg führen darf
dass man das nicht durchgehen lässt was
muss die NATO was muss der Westen jetzt
tun
die westlichen Staaten haben sich
entschieden dass sie nicht direkt
militärisch in der Ukraine intervenieren
werden darauf haben sich alle
NATO-Staaten geeinigt und haben gesagt
dass ein direktes intervenieren
beispielsweise über eine nofly Zone oder
direkt in der Ukraine dass das dass sie
das ausschließen weil sie das Risiko zu
groß ansehen in einen direkten Krieg mit
Russland involviert zu werden und dann
hätten wir einer noch viel schlimmere
Katastrophe als wir sie jetzt schon
haben das heißt es gibt eine Linie der
NATO die sagt keine direktem
militärische Intervention das heißt es
bleiben für die westlichen Staaten de
facto 2
Optionen oder zwei Wege wie Sie die
Ukraine unterstützen können das eine
sind die Wirtschaftssanktionen die USA
haben die Sanktionen noch mal verschärft
das ist auch die ganze Frage des Energie
am bargus beispielsweise und die zweite
Option ist die militärische
Unterstützung für die Ukraine noch mal
weiter zu intensivieren die Ukraine hat
eine lange Liste von von Sachen die sie
braucht und die ihr jetzt helfen würden
das sind relativ einfache Dinge wie
beispielsweise Treibstoff noch mal
Russland die die Treibstofflager
systematisch zerstört hat aber es geht
auch um Artillerie es geht um Munition
es geht um gepanzerte Fahrzeuge es geht
um um Panzer das heißt um um Flugabwehr
das heißt es gibt eine sehr lange Liste
die die Ukraine befähigen soll sich
besser zu verteidigen gegen Russland
aber darüber hinaus auch Gebiete
zurückzuerobern und die Frage ist ob die
NATO-Staaten jeder einzelne und auch das
Bündnis an sich bereit sind jetzt noch
mehr und schwereres Gerät
bereitzustellen das ist eine der Themen
die auch auf dem Treffen der
NATO-Außenminister besprochen werden
heute dann schauen wir uns zum Ende des
Gesprächs noch einmal das an was sie
eingangs auch genannt haben das
Kriegsziel Putins das ist immer noch die
Ukraine zu vernichten zu denazifizieren
sowie er das nennt und wir haben gesehen
dass der russische autotimo Facer Gates
einen Gastbeitrag veröffentlicht hat in
der russischen Nachrichtenagentur RIA
Novosti ein klassisches Beispiel für
russische Propaganda in der zur
Vernichtung der Ukraine aufgerufen wird
da hören wir kurz rein
die weitere Entnazifizierung dieser
Bevölkerungsmasse besteht in der
Umerziehung die durch ideologische
Unterdrückung der
nationalsozialistischen Gesinnung und
strenge Zensur erreicht wird nicht nur
im politischen Bereich sondern
notwendigerweise auch im Bereich der
Kultur und der Erziehung in dieser
Hinsicht kann ein entnazifiziertes Land
nicht souverän sein der Name Ukraine
kann offensichtlich nicht als Titel
eines vollständig entnazifizierten
Staatsgebildes in einem vom Nazi-Regime
befreiten Gebiet beibehalten werden
tja das was hier in einer Art Ideologie
veröffentlicht wurde ist es das was
putin will
wenn man sich frühere Ausführungen auch
von Putin ansieht dann hat er ganz klar
der Ukraine eine eigene Identität
abgesprochen und hat gesagt sie hat
eigentlich nicht die rechtfertigt
eigentlich ist das Recht als eigenes
unabhängiges Land zu existieren sondern
gehört eigentlich historisch und auch
von der Identität her zu Russland das
heißt er hat die Ukraine der eigene
Staatlichkeit abgesprochen und die die
ursprünglichen Ziele die man am Anfang
aus den russischen Aussagen herleiten
konnte war die Einnahme von Kiew war ein
Systemwechsel das heißt die demokratisch
gewählte Regierung um selensky zu
stürzen entweder durch einer
Marionettenregierung oder eine
Militärregierung zu ersetzen die Eliten
auszutauschen das ist dieses
schreckliche Wort der denazifizierung
und diese Entmilitarisierung was de
facto heißt die Ukraine von ihren
wirtschaftlichen Strukturen zu anzeigen
und wenn man diese vier Punkte
zusammenzählt und auch sich jetzt
anguckt was die russische Kriegsführung
hinterlassen hat in der Ukraine dann
geht es darum die Ukraine
in einer Art vasalenstaat von Russland
zu verwandeln
und das sind auch letztlich die großen
Fragen die die geklärt werden oder die
für die Ukraine auf dem Spiel stehen das
ist dies das Überleben als ein
souveräner
eigener Staat
in den Grenzen die vor der Invasion vom
24 Februar waren und in Zukunft drittens
mit Sicherheitsgarantien dass andere
Länder wirklich dafür bürgen in Zukunft
dass so ein Krieg so eine Bedrohung
nicht noch mal stattfindet das heißt wir
sehen in dem Text den sie eben gezeigt
haben aber auch in den in den Reden von
russischen Regierungsvertretern wirklich
dieses Ziel die Ukraine hat keiner
Daseinsberechtigung als souveräner Staat
sie wollen die Ukraine als Souverän
Staat der selber entscheiden kann ob er
mit dem besten kooperiert oder nicht
diese Ukraine hat aus russischer Sicht
offensichtlich keine Daseinsberechtigung
und wenn das ist ein Satz noch dann muss
eigentlich für uns als westliche Staaten
es eine umso größere Aufgabe sein die
ukra jetzt zu unterstützen bei so ein
Angriffs- und Vernichtungskrieg kein
Erfolg haben darf
Frau major ich hätte gerne noch über
Dimitri mit ihnen gesprochen der unter
anderem davon träumt einen freies
Eurasien von Wladiwostok bis Lissabon
zu errichten er hat letzte Woche schon
mit der Atombombe gedroht diese Woche
ist es diese Vision ein Spiel mit der
Angst die er damit auch im Westen
hervorrufen möchte aber mit Blick auf
die Kommentare mache ich das nicht
sondern versuche so eine Art
schnellantwort Runde noch mit ihnen zu
machen denn ich sehe es gibt so
unglaublich viele Fragen an Sie ein ein
User fragt zum Beispiel Frau major
sollte Deutschland nicht auch
Angriffswaffen liefern mit der Bitte um
nur kurze Antwort dann schaffe ich noch
zwei mehr die ganz kurze Antwort ist ja
aber wenn ich darf trotzdem noch zwei
Sätze
wir wollen die Ukraine unterstützen dass
sie nicht nur sich besser verteidigen
kann sondern dass sie die Gebiete die
Russland bereits besetzt hat
zurückerobern kann
und das ist wichtig gerade auch wenn man
die Ereignisse in Wutscher sieht oder
den Bericht aus mariopol den wir auch
kurz vorher gesehen haben es geht um für
die Ukraine nicht nur um Verteilungen es
geht darum die besetzten Gebiete zurück
zu erobern weil man auch sieht was unter
russischer Besatzung passiert ist in
butja oder in mariopol das heißt ja es
geht auch um Angriffswaffen nämlich um
ukrainisches Territorium zurückzuerobern
Nolde fragt über Youtube gibt es
irgendwann eine rote Linie
für wen
das wiederum steht leider nicht dabei
ich interpretiere das jetzt mal so für
die NATO dass man eines Tages doch sagt
okay es ist zwar kein Bündnisfall aber
wir sehen angesichts der Verbrechen die
dort begangen werden wir haben eine
moralische Pflicht einzugreifen ich
hoffe ich habe die Frage richtig
verstanden bis Akinator eine sehr klare
Position vertreten nämlich zu sagen die
NATO ist ein Verteidigungsbündnis die
Aufgabe ist es die 30 Mitglieder zu
schützen das ist eine Lebensversicherung
für die 30 Alliierten und das ist ihre
Hauptaufgabe und auch die gesamten
militärischen Anpassungsmaßnahmen die
die NATO in den letzten Wochen
beschlossen hat also mehr Truppen an der
Grenze mehr Luftüberwachung mehr sehr
räumüberwachung Aktivierung der
verteidigungspläne die haben alle einen
defensiven und nicht eskalatorischen
Charakter weil die NATO sich wirklich
auf diese schutzversprechen für die
eigenen Alliierten konzentrieren möchte
sie hat darüber hinaus gesagt sie möchte
die Ukraine Unterstützung mit
Waffenlieferung beispielsweise wird auf
dem Gipfel heute und morgen soll auch
beschlossen werden noch mal mehr Waffen
und noch mal mehr Unterstützung
beispielsweise auch im
kampfschutzausrüstung gegen biologische
und chemische Waffen zu liefern sie hat
aber auch ganz klar gemacht dass die
NATO nicht direkt intervenieren wird
weil die Sorge über eine noch viel
größere Eskalation sehr groß ist und
mein Eindruck ist dass sich diese rote
Linie keine direkte militärische
Intervention dass sich die verändert hat
dass man aber unterhalb dieser Linie
versucht deutlich mehr zu machen mit
schwererem Gerät und möglicherweise auch
westliche Ausrüstung
allerletzte Frage Wolfgang fragt über
youtube hat Russland die Manpower andere
Länder parallel anzugreifen
das hängt von der Form des Angriffs ab
deshalb kann man die Frage nicht so
einfach beantworten man kann sich auch
angucken wie die Truppenstationierung
gerade sind
unterzeichnet sich gerade im Moment ein
anderer Angriff nicht ab man kann aber
auch sagen dass man ein anderes Land
unter der Schwelle eines militärischen
Konflikts unter einer Schwelle eines
militärischen Angriffs auch
destabilisieren kann russland hat die
Ukraine seit 2014 unterhalb der Schwelle
eines offenen Krieges destabilisiert
über Cyber-Angriffe über Fake News über
wirtschaftlichen Druck über kleinere
militärische Vorfälle an der
kontaktlinie das heißt die
Destabilisierung geht unterhalb der
Schwelle eines Krieges und auch
Konflikte kann man unterhalb der
Schwelle eines Krieges austragen und das
ist in der Tat eine eine große Sorge für
all die Länder die nicht unter dem
Schutzschirm der NATO und der EU stehen
also Georgien Moldau und Bosnien
insbesondere
sagt Dr Claudia major vielen herzlichen
Dank für diese
Ausführungen auch am Ende noch in in
ganz kurzer Power vielen Dank dass Sie
heute Abend mit in unserer Sendung waren
und damit gehe ich weiter an dieser
Stelle nicht zu Vladimir Putin sondern
zu unserem Korrespondenten in Brüssel
florian neuhahn ist für uns dort vor Ort
denn auch heute wieder finden dort
verschiedene
Gipfel statt unter anderem ein Treffen
der NATO-Außenminister und der
EU-Botschafter da ist er Florian
beginnen wir mit dem worüber die NATO
derzeit mutmaßlich noch berät ich glaube
dass Abendessen ist vorbei ich weiß es
nicht genau wirst Du uns gleich updaten
aber wer setzt sich denn durch was was
ist worauf deuten die Hinweise die die
auf Dialog setzen mit Russland oder die
die sagen nach dem was wir zum Beispiel
in Butcher gesehen haben kann es keinen
Dialog mit Russland mehr geben
ja guten Abend erstmal also das
Abendessen nach allem was ich weiß es
läuft noch die Außenminister beraten zu
Stunde auch über einen strategisches
Konzept für die nächsten 4 5 Jahre wie
sich die NATO da eben aufstellen soll
und wenn sie dann von Dialog reden dann
meinen sie nicht jetzt den direkten
Dialog jetzt mit Wladimir Putin das ist
für die Alliierten glaube ich allesamt
ausgeschlossen man kann mit Vladimir
Putin nicht auf Augenhöhe geradezu als
Partner noch nach solchen Massakern wie
dem von Butcher reden wenn ihr von
Dialog gesprochen wird meint man den
Dialog mit einem Russland nach dem Krieg
und an Russland auch nach Putin und da
gibt es schon zwei Linien in der NATO
würde ich sagen die man da eindeutig
identifizieren kann das eine sind die
Hardliner die Falken sozusagen die sagen
wir machen jetzt wir installieren jetzt
eine Friedensordnung gegen Russland ohne
Russland und können auch damit Russland
nicht mehr normal wie vor der Krise vor
dem Krieg reden
und es gibt andere Länder zu denen auch
Deutschland gehört die sagen wir müssen
diese Realität anerkennen das Land ist
nun mal da wir müssen irgendwann auch
wieder Kommunikationskanäle mit Russland
haben mit einem Russland nach Putin
wer sich dadurch setzt ist schwer zu
sagen in der öffentlichen Wahrnehmung in
der Debatte sind die Falken meines
Erachtens lauter aber das entspricht
nicht unbedingt der
Mehrheitsverhältnissen am Ende wird sich
die realistisch die realpolitische
Variante auch in der Kommunikation der
NATO meines Erachtens wiederfinden aber
nochmal es geht jetzt nicht um den
direkten Dialog jetzt nach Butcher
sondern eher um so einen kleinen
Ausblick für die nächsten vier fünf oder
sogar zehn Jahre
einen Usernamens Billy Maze Rolf fragt
über Youtube Russe oder sagt Russland
darf nicht einfach so gewinnen das ist
ihnen klar Fragezeichen auch wenn Krieg
schrecklich ist kann man den Angreifer
nicht einfach profitieren lassen Waffen
für die Verteidiger sind ein Muss auch
das ist ja eine Frage über die die NATO
diskutiert und auch da ist die Frage
welche Form von Waffen sollte man
liefern und sollten es schwere Waffen
sein wie ist die Position dazu
ja das haben wir auch gerade von Frau
major gehört es gibt da durchaus einen
leichten Strategiewechsel den keiner so
nennen will aber dem man durchaus
beobachten kann dieser Krieg ist jetzt
in einer neuen Phase Russland zieht sich
von dem großen Angriff auf Kiew erst
einmal zurück sammelt die Truppen neu
ist es unklar welches Ziel man weiterhin
verfolgt ob nur den Don Bass oder sogar
weiterhin die Stoltenberg den
Nato-Generalsekretär heute sagte die
gesamte Ukraine aber NATO starten sagen
jetzt müssen man die Ukraine befähigen
auch mit offensiv Waffen russische
Truppen zurückzuschlagen also gebietet
zurückzuerobern und da kommt dieser
Strategiewechsel ins Spiel also nicht
mehr nur defensiv Waffen wie
Panzerfäuste oder Flugabwehrraketen zu
liefern sondern eben auch Panzer mit
denen man angreifen kann
es gibt erste Länder die das tun
Tschechien ist jetzt vorgeprescht hat
Dutzende von Schützenpanzern T-72
sowjetischer Bauart witzigerweise
geliefert Deutschland ist auch da
zurückhaltender es gibt die Anfrage der
Ukraine nach marda Kampfpanzern
hundertmarder Kampfpanzer der Bundeswehr
das ist die Bitte der Ukraine die
Bundesregierung ist da noch sehr
zurückhaltend unter anderem auch weil
sie sich fragt ob denn in der Ukraine in
der Armee überhaupt Menschen da sind die
diese Panzer warten oder auch fahren
können insofern das ist eine Diskussion
die man führt es gibt noch kein
eindeutiges Ergebnis Florian hier gibt
es eine Frage an Herrn Neuhann also an
Dich gibt es Hinweise darauf dass
Finnland und Schweden der NATO beitreten
werden jetzt sollten bei hat sich heute
ja auch in dieser Richtung geäußert
kannst du das Beantworten ja das ist
eine wirklich spektakuläre Entwicklung
diese beiden Länder sind seit
Jahrzehnten ja souverän und neutral und
auch stolz darauf dass sie neutral sind
sie gehören der EU an aber eben nicht
der NATO dieser Krieg dieser
Angriffskrieg russland hat die beiden
Länder der NATO extrem viel näher
gebracht und in der Tat die Anzeichen
mit mehreren sich das beide Länder jetzt
offenbar gewählt sind der NATO auf kurze
Frist beizutreten die NATO bereitet sich
zumindest darauf vor das hat auch Jens
deutenberg heute gesagt und wenn es
einen Antrag einen Beitrittsantrag der
beiden Länder findet und Schwedens gibt
dann wird die NATO diesen sehr sehr
schnell Stadt geben das heißt man wird
diese beiden Länder sehr sehr schnell
aufnehmen und die Freude darüber bei der
Allianz ist dann doch sehr groß
es gab gestern einen Diplomaten der
sagte das wäre wirklich unglaublich
fantastisch man hätte sich das nicht
träumen lassen können wladimir Putin hat
mit seinem Ziel mit seinem Krieg auch
eines erreicht er hat die NATO
wahnsinnig gestärkt und attraktiv
gemacht eben auch für Länder die
jahrzehntelang keinen Gedanken daran
verschwendet haben dieser Allianz
beizutreten
Florian ich sehe hier gerade einen
user-kommentar von Tobias unknown der
schreibt über Youtube das ZDF wirkt bei
jeder Live-Sendung so als wäre das ihre
erste das finde ich in der Tat ein
bisschen unfair weil ja wir hatten oft
Streams wo der Ton nicht funktioniert
hat oder wo die Leitungen nicht standen
oder so aber heute lief tatsächlich
alles glatt also an diesem Tag Tobias
unknown ist diese Kritik muss ich sagen
wirklich umberechtigt Florian noch mal
zum Inhalt wir kommen zur EU zu
Sanktionen die dort möglicherweise auf
den Tisch liegen wir sehen die USA haben
gerade neue Sanktionen beschlossen zwei
große russische Banken sowie die
erwachsenen Kinder von Präsident Putin
und Außenminister lavrov sind betroffen
was plant die EU
ja wenn Sie jetzt die Kinder ansprechen
das plant die EU auch die erwachsenen
Töchter von Wladimir Putin das haben uns
Diplomaten heute bestätigt die sollen
ebenfalls auf die Sanktionsliste der EU
aufgeführt werden das heißt da gibt es
einen Einreiseverbot das gegen sie
verhängt wird und ihre Vermögen in der
Europäischen Union wenn sie welche haben
die werden eingefroren auch ansonsten
werden die bestehenden Sanktionen noch
mal verschärft etwa im Finanzsektor und
das wichtigste was die Kommission
vorgeschlagen hat das bezieht sich auf
den Energiesektor gestern hat die
Kommission vorgeschlagen und der Rat
wird dem wahrscheinlich heute folgen
dass man einen Importstopp verhängt auf
russisches russische Kohle also nicht
auf die gesamte Energie nicht auf Gas
nicht auf Öl aber eben auf Kohle das ist
an erster Schritt der manchen zu weit
oder nicht weit genug geht
Florian letzte Frage du kennst lange
verhandlungsnächte der EU welche Nacht
liegt davor euch wie die nächsten Tage
wir werden die sein wie ist es um die
Einigkeit der EU bestellt ist man da
klar oder wird es da viele Diskussionen
geben
ob das heute eine lange Nacht wird das
weiß ich nicht aber die nächsten Tage
und Wochen die werden natürlich sehr
sehr stark bestimmt sein von diesen
Diskussionen die Einigkeit der EU die
war bis zum Kriegsbeginn und auch in den
ersten Tagen und Wochen danach noch sehr
groß aber jetzt in der Tat da werden die
Gräben immer tiefer wir haben gerade
eben mit dem litauischen Außenminister
gabrielos landsberges gesprochen der
sich von den neuerlichen Sanktionen der
EU der den sein Land ja der Salat ja
auch angehört vollkommen enttäuscht
zeigte sagte dieses Sanktionspaket sei
völlig unzureichend
andere wiederum da sehen wir etwa den
ungarischen Ministerpräsidenten Viktor
Orban gerade wiedergewählt die sagen
uns gegen diese Sanktionen eigentlich zu
weit er sei sogar bereit russisches Gas
künftig auch in Rubel zu bezahlen wenn
Putin das so wollen da sieht man diese
beiden Pole der EU und die Gräben
zwischen den beiden Polen die werden
immer tiefer
mit der Einigkeit ist es nicht mehr so
weit her vielleicht noch ein Satz dazu
ein Diplomat sagte mir gestern Moskau
setzt darauf dass der Westen dass die
Einigkeit des Westens irgendwann
auseinander zu brechen droht wir müssen
daran arbeiten sagte er dass das nicht
passiert aber das wird von Tag zu Tag
immer schwerer
vielen Dank Florian Neuhann nach Brüssel
für diese Einschätzung danke schön
Florian und ich bedanke mich ganz
herzlich bei Euch und Ihnen fürs
zuschauen und mit kommentieren danke und
liebe Grüße an dieser Stelle auch an
Paul der über Youtube schreibt also ich
mag das ZDF liebe Grüße aus Österreich
danke dafür Paul liebe Grüße zurück und
ich sage Tschüss im Namen des Teams bis
zum nächsten Mal tschüss
[Musik]